ce soit que je constate qu'il ya
probablement eu énormément de stupidité
humaine pour qu'on en arrive là une
deuxième fois
sarr est le message très tendance et la
population s'est il faudrait pas que ça
arrive une troisième fois on va essayer
de tout faire en une deuxième fois mon
troisième est ce qu'on va être capable
de le faire cette fois-ci puis ça vaille
de puiser dans l'argent de tout le monde
pour nous permettre de survivre
je bosse sur qu'il s'attendait à tout le
monde de payer pour la survie des bars
ou des restaurants
françois meunier vice président aux
affaires publiques et gouvernementales
de l'association restauration québec
bonsoir monsieur meunier votre réaction
l annonce du gouvernement aujourd'hui
écoutés on est sous chaque vraiment ce
choc on est irritée également on trouve
que c'est injuste on a fait tellement
d'efforts depuis la réouverture des
salles à manger depuis le mois de juin
pour offrir à notre clientèle à d'autres
travailleurs un environnement de travail
en environnement
une expérience en restauration
sécuritaire on investit de l'argent en
plexiglas un masque un produit assez
petit et ce sans aucun acte de l'état et
le devoir aujourd'hui de devoir se
recombiner de devoir fermer nos salles à
manger
c'est extrêmement frustrant pour nous
parce que l'essentiel de tous les
restaurants la grande majorité des
restera appliquée à la lettre toutes les
modalités toutes les consignes qui était
qui était demandé par le gouvernement
écrit nous on est très fier très fier du
travail qui a été fait par nos jeunes a
bien sûr des cas d'exception
mais le grand moment a les moyens
d'assurer une surveillance par les
policiers pour la santé publique dans un
environnement comme un restaurant ce qui
est pas le cas des maisons depuis depuis
en fait la semaine dernière jeudi à de
nombreux sur de nombreuses prix tribune
de premier ministre a répété une des
dizaines de fois que c'était pas les
bars étaient pas les restaurants qui
était le problème c'est lé rassemblement
privé alors on est un peu dubitatif
aujourd'hui le devoir a évidemment en
étant on pense qu'on est un peu un
symbole ou des boucs émissaires pour que
le commun puisse envoyer un message à la
population que l'on doit complètement
cessé nos contacts sociaux
vous savez nous on était prête à faire
des sacrifices il refus on aurait pu
avoir des mesures de remplacement qui
aurait été davantage
ankara contraignant mais somme toute
aumône aurait pu garder nos salles à
manger aux verts je vous rappelle me
suffit léon là qu'on est dans une
industrie qui est déjà très fragilisée
par l'aco vide sinon l'une des plus
fragilisés et c'est pas juste 28 jours
qui nous inquiète c'est l'émoi aussi qui
vont suivre le mois de novembre s'est
jamais un bon mois le mois de décembre
c'est un le meilleur mot pour la période
des feuilles qui dans les entreprises
vont inviter des clients ou des du
personnel à souper au restaurant en
décembre 2020 alors pour nous c'est déjà
une période qui était oublié et on devra
on est très contents d'entendre le 1er
mai le dire que finalement ils vont
avoir des mesures d'âge parce qu'on va
en avoir besoin
vous avez besoin de mesure d'être vous
demandez quoi précisément terme dead
ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on en
demandait dans le contexte d'un re
confinement c'est certain pour nous
qu'on devra s'attaquer au fameux
problème des loyers le héros né le 1er
octobre jeudi le 1er octobre
habituellement lors il ya un loyer à
payer il ya de nombreux restaurateurs
qui est qui sont déjà en arrérages des
loyers des derniers mots et il ya plus
de programmes d aide au fédéral pour le
paiement des loyers commerciaux
on devra aussi empêcher l'expulsion pour
non paiement de loyer on est au québec
la seule province à ne pas avoir
finalement réussi à faire passer ça le
1er octobre au silo erreur un peu c'est
un peu particulier par cette première
top c'est le versement des taxes de
vente des psd vécu alors la même journée
qu'on dit aux restaurateurs on va vous
fermez vos salles à manger mais
envoyez-nous les textes que vous avez
perçu dans les derniers mois oui alors
il ya beaucoup de choses comme ce qui
ajoute à nos difficultés et on devra
très certainement aussi offrir un congé
de taxes foncières ont été fermés trois
mois les moddeurs avril mais presque jeu
au complet et on nous affirme un autre
mot complet trois ou quatre mois son
discours koné dont victor l enfermer
monsieur meunier depuis le début de la
pandémie définitivement en fait c'est
extrêmement difficile de dresser un
portrait à ce moment ci parce que
notamment je vous dis j'ai vu les
chiffres de faillite pour 2010 pour le
mois d'août
alors il ya eu au moins de faillites en
2020 qu'en 2019 à pourquoi parce que
finalement on vit sur du temps emprunté
les programmes mis sur pied au fédéral
on supporter les entreprises d'une
manière très concret la subvention
salariale d'urgence a été d'un souk aux
importants ce qui nous est finalement
quand on regarde peu la la la la la
performance de la saison estivale 2020
sur le plan touristique les québécois
sont restés ici donc des endroits comme
le mont tremblant la côte-nord
charlevoix le bas-saint-laurent la
gaspésie
on a sauvé la mise il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui finalement ont pu se sortir
la tête de l'eau dans le contexte mais
c'est pas du tout cas de montréal à
montréal quartier des spectacles
quartier des affaires car si historique
vous avez vous savez on peine à avoir à
peine 10 15% des ventes alors on devra
peut-être faire un ciblage au niveau des
programmes died est trop certaines notes
montréal de vaud devra être supporter
davantage que d'autres villes
merci monsieur meunier bonne chose merci
monsieur fillon